for the second time in just a week the
president of the European commission
along with Italian and Dutch prime
ministers have come to Tunisia for talks
with President ice Syed
their main focus is migration smuggling
and economic cooperation
the European commission is considering
macro financial assistance as soon as
the necessary agreement is found
and we are ready to mobilize up to 900
million euros for this purpose of
microfinancial assistance
as an immediate step
we could provide an additional
up to 150 million euros in budget
support right now a joint statement
issued after the talks stressed the need
to combat illegal migration to and from
Tunisia and prevent death satsi
a generous European package comes in
response to a combination of challenges
facing Tunisia at the moment it includes
worsening economic conditions and an
influx of migrants from other African
nations trying to reach European coasts
through Tunisia
here in the province of spatz on the
Gulf of gabis a large number of migrants
and refugees are waiting for the
opportunity to take to the Sea Tunisian
president Christ ayed who visited the
area stressed his view that any solution
to the issue of migration should not
come at the expense of Tunisia
they are victims victims of a global
system that unfortunately treats them
not as human beings but as numbers we
cannot play the role that some play
openly and others hide be in Gods for
their countries the solution can only be
Humane Collective and based on the law
this treaty will have bad consequences
if it will be coupled with other
bilateral agreements between the EU and
the transit countries on the
Mediterranean which due to their
suffering economies tend to turn into
Gathering points for illegal migrants
European countries fear the potential
deterioration of the economic situation
in Tunisia could make it more difficult
to control migration flows while human
rights organizations are concerned The
Joint measures between Tunisia and the
EU could lead to the mistreatment of
migrants they are asked in Tunisia not
to facilitate the forced return of
refugees intercepted at sea or from the
European Coastal
now the EU money that's on offer is